all right so the flash is sprinting into
theaters in less than two months but a
couple days ago a bevy of news outlets
critics and influencers were treated to
an early screening of an almost complete
version of the film at cinemacon this
means a ton of new information about the
film has hit the socials so we here at
heavy spoilers are lacing up our tennies
and running straight into all of this
new information all of this is heavily
rumored but to play things safe this is
going to contain heavy alleged spoilers
for the upcoming Flash movie if you want
to go into that movie completely fresh I
recommend you turn around now and walk
away but if not thanks for joining us
please hit that like button and be sure
to subscribe for breakdowns and other
videos like this daily with all of that
out of the way thank you so much for
clicking this I'm your host Jared now
now again I want to preface everything
by saying take everything we talk about
here with a grain of salt these details
are from others that attended the
cinemacon flash preview with portions of
the movie specifically the CGI being
unfinished some of this could change by
the time the final theatrical version is
released so anyone saying in the
comments that their Uncle who works for
DC said otherwise honestly it might be
true this time around but kicking things
off the flash apparently starts with The
Flash and Batman teaming up chasing some
bank robbers that have a contingency
plan to blow up a nearby hospital if
their demands are not met in this action
sequence The Flash zooms through saving
all of the doctors and patients similar
to his speed scenes in Justice League
while Batman swoops in stopping the
bombs and capturing the robbers an
action-packed intro to this 2 hour and
30-ish minute movie as we're kind of
shown in origin sequence featuring Barry
gaining his powers after he's struck by
a bolt of of lightning while trying to
investigate and gather clues about his
mother's murder back in 2013. it's also
revealed Barry was present at the Battle
of metropolis featured in Man of Steel
helping to evacuate citizens now things
jump back to present day as Barry
apparently is in court trying to fight
for his fathers Henry Allen released
from prison however proves unsuccessful
Ben Affleck's Bruce Wayne picks him up
from the courthouse and they discuss how
it may be possible for Barry to travel
quick enough through time and go back
and save his mother the night that she
was unfortunately killed however Bruce
reassures them of the dangers stating
that one little tiny insignificant
change could have a massive ripple
effect Barry of course doesn't listen to
Bruce's advice and runs he just he runs
so far away back to 2001 and steals a
can of tomato soup from the local
grocery store this of course forces
Barry's mother to go to a different
store because you know she wanted the
tomato soup so isn't home during the
time of her murder in the original
timeline Barry thinks he has solved all
of his problems casually speed running
back to 2003 but during this a
mysterious other Speedster creature who
we find out later to be dark flash
attacks Barry sending him spiraling into
2013 rather than 2003. here he finds his
mother still alive and meets his younger
self but present Barry soon realizes
past Berry won't get his speed force
Powers because his mother is alive in
this new timeline and he will never
investigate her murder hence being
struck by lightning and so forth that
night the two go back and forth on
whether or not this lightning strike
will in fact occur or not when prison
Barry is struck by lightning and loses
his powers it didn't happen to past
Barry so therefore present buried the
berry that started this movie never
received his powers this is where the
events of Man of Steel get all screwy
Louie as General Zod around lives to
Earth but Henry cavill's Superman is
nowhere to be found maybe you should
have paid him more yet Chumps sorry but
uh yeah uh the two berries go off to
Wayne Manor in Gotham City to ask Batman
to help with their situation but upon
arriving it is no longer Ben Affleck's
Batman like in present day but rather an
aged and retired Michael Keaton Batman
you want to get nuts
foreign
with all of these Oddities Barry
realizes that he accidentally Tangled
different timelines together when he
changed the past and of course like any
time traveled Back to the Future like
movie needs to fix the timeline Bruce in
his curmudgeon attitude old retired
phase reluctantly agrees to help the
pair and Suits up mission one is where
the heck is Superman at this time so
Batman locates what he thinks is Kal-El
to a military base somewhere in Siberia
and the mission is to break him out of
there but to their surprise instead of
Kalel they find his cousin Zara core L
AKA Supergirl who was captured as a
child upon arriving to Earth and has
been locked up her entire life the group
helps her escape the dark depths of the
prison as she then abandons the group
upon reaching sunlight and activating
her powers though she quickly returns to
save the others from a horror words of
the guards they then gather back up at
Wayne Manor where past Berry starts to
develop a crush on Supergirl oh love is
in the air okay uh apparently here is
where the group tries to devise a plan
to get Barry's powers back first with
Batman trying some electrocution
techniques science project but uh of
course it's a fail instead Kara flies
Barry into a storm allowing him to be
struck by lightning which seemingly
restores his powers like it was nothing
shocking right Zod is still on his
journey of taking over Earth with him
terraforming with the world engine in
the same Desert from Man of Steel
instead of the heart of metropolis the
two flashes Batman and Supergirl
confront him leading to a massive battle
between the two sides which was heavily
featured in this latest trailer for the
movie apparently this battle has played
out several times with it always ending
with Batman and or Supergirl dying The
Flash has traveled back in time a
handful of times but cannot seem to
prevent this moment present Barry
determines that this is a fixed point in
the timelines but past Barry a bit more
immature of course you know newer with
his powers refuses to accept this fate
and continues over and over and over
again until he vanishes into the speed
force however past Berry doesn't return
it is instead dark flash with present
Barry realizing that this is actually a
future version of pastberry who was
spent his entire life resenting a
present Barry for changing everything
you know the berry who is selfish and
completely messed up the timelines now
it's saying this is your stereotypical
just evil up the main character same
moveset in a metaphorical face yourself
your problems in the moment but it kind
of sounds like that but rumored dark
flash has spent years traveling through
time trying hundreds if not thousands of
permutations of events without success
but has come to believe that this one
thing that could fix everything is by
killing present Barry which in turn
would save the world and correct these
Divergence president Barry realizes the
massive mistake he has made and tries to
race back through time to undo these
actions but dark flash chases after him
as he considers prison Barry to be too
dangerous to live just as dark flash is
about to kill prison Barry pastberry
returns from earlier in his timeline and
sacrifices himself to present Barry
causing dark flash to vanish allowing
prison Barry to travel back to 2001 and
fix the whole soup Fiasco there's
there's a lot of berries but he's fixing
it now this is apparently a cameo filled
what if buffet for comic book fans
because while traveling back through
time Barry travels through different
timelines and universes leading to
cameos from Christopher Reeves Superman
Adam West's Batman Linda Carter's Wonder
Woman Nicholas Cage yeah Nicholas
cage as Superman from the scrapped Tim
Burton Superman movie Superman lives if
you haven't yet there's an awesome
documentary about this called The Death
of Superman lives what happened I
recommend checking it out but anyway I'm
getting off topic George Clooney's
Batman makes an appearance alongside
Teddy sear Zoom or black flash so I'm
sure hardcore fans will be screaming
let's go during this whole rumored
sequence Barry back in 2001 puts the can
of soup back on the shelf and
accidentally bumps into his mother Nora
Allen they share an emotional tender
moment together as Barry lets her go
knowing that later that night she is
going to die having corrected his
problems Barry Speed runs back to his
present day only to find that his
present day isn't the way he remembers
it to be this looks like an entirely
different Universe where Barry
encounters a completely different Batman
whose face we do not see leaving his
face ambiguous and for everyone out
there including us here at heavy
spoilers to theorize over who this could
be until it's announced Channing Tatum
as Batman and Superman will be Jonah
Hill we're about to announce the new
Superman the new Superman is
Jonah Hill [__] there have been reports
of multiple cameos having been cut due
to the different direction of the future
dce movies and where they're going like
Henry Cavill and Gal Gadot having Cameo
roles in this Flash movie but the
general structure of the edit and events
seemed to be right on the money with
previous rumors that we've read it
sounds like a big all one Multiverse
Thai mess up self-discovery face your
own personal demons forget and forgive
the past type story I guess the question
is if all of these rumors are in fact
true where the hell does The Flash and
mysterious Batman go from here but yeah
that is everything we allegedly know
about the upcoming Flash movie out of
cinemacon it sounds like DC's Wild Ride
answer to Multiverse of Madness but yeah
I would love to hear your thoughts on
the flash below does this sound like a
nice soft reboot to the DC EU or is this
going to be another C CGI flop for the
James Gunn and Company and I'll let you
know we're currently running a
competition giving away three copies of
Ant-Man quantumania on the 15th of May
and all you got to do to get a chance of
winning this is like this video make
sure to subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below on your
thoughts of The Flash movie we pick the
comments at random at the end of every
single month in the winners of last
month are on screen right now so if
that's you message us on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out some
of our other cool videos right over
there click one clickety clack do it but
with all of that out of the way thank
you so much thank you for your constant
support I've been Jared I'll see in the
next one take care and peace